um when we talk about 2022 and I do
believe we are now officially in the
midterm uh period you know we've been
talking before about usually the
midterms really heat up in June or July
and this time around it might be may it
might even be late April I believe that
with the start of Trump's 2022 rallies
over the weekend and just with the
amount of interest and discussion that's
already taking place about specific 2022
races including Dr Oz uh I'm sorry
Mehmet Oz I'm I'm doing it too we need
memet Oz running in in Pennsylvania
um with the discussions about what
appear to be shoe and trumpists that
will easily sail to re-election you know
many of their names I won't repeat them
it seems pretty clear that the 2022
midterms have begun and one of the
reasons that the 2022 midterms are
important are that if Republicans take
the house in 2022 the investigation into
the Trump riots is over so there's
urgency for it to be completed before
the November elections that's number one
number two the success of trump
endorsees in 2022 May well be a signal
about 2024 in terms of Trump's interest
in running Trump's likelihood and
running okay that's another reason but
there's a third really important
category as to why 2022 matters which is
depending on what happens in 2022 not
only in the House and Senate but very
importantly in in races within States
Governors secretaries of state and here
we go now election supervisors the
Republican Party may be in a better
position in 2024.
to successfully steal an election they
unsuccessfully tried to steal an
election in 2020 depending on what
happens in 2022 they may be in a real
position to to actually succeed at
stealing an election in 2024 and we have
video here of Donald Trump just
admitting it uh this is video and
remember they tried with raffensberger
in Georgia and it didn't work but had
different people been there in Georgia
it might actually have worked so here
Donald Trump in a video message to the
Pennsylvania Republican party he
explains why he is focusing on
supervisor of elections races in 2022
he's admitting the strategy out loud my
friends take a look at this it would be
a lot sharper the next time when it
comes to counting the vote is a famous
statement sometimes the vote counter is
more important than the candidate and we
can't let that ever ever happen again
they have to get tougher and smarter so
when Trump says we need tougher and
smarter people counting the ballots
running elections what he's saying is we
need to more effectively put our people
in control of Elections so that when I
lose
um I can just have someone figure out a
way to make me win remember him
demanding the 11 000 votes
right that was with Georgia so we've
known that this is the strategy
and Donald Trump is admitting that this
is the strategy and this is one of the
major reasons why Donald Trump is going
to be so involved in the 2022 Races they
are going to try again and remember
we've we've gone through these different
scenarios if Trump had had some
friendlier people in three or four
states it's not a guarantee that it
would have gone a different way but it
would have significantly upped the odds
that even though Trump lost he might
have been able to stay in power it upped
the odds I'm not saying it made it
likely but it upped the odds if
raffensberger had been willing
could have flipped Georgia right I mean
at the end of the day 11 000 votes as
Donald Trump said uh We've now heard
from retired generals from the military
who have warned and said if the military
brass
had been willing and interested in
helping
you could have had the assistance of the
military in carrying out the coup
didn't have it in 2020 what if that
changed and there is no doubt whatsoever
where this is heading Joseph Stalin said
in 1923 quote I consider it completely
unimportant who in the party will Vote
or how but what is extraordinarily
important is this who will count the
votes and how and he is saying that he
wants them to be better at stealing
elections period And so how do we I I've
talked before about the difficulty of
playing defense against this
they might have 12 strategies
and we need to know all 12 and know how
to defend against them we might only
know how to defend against 11 and that
12th strategy is what could be the
Difference Maker so they're doing
gerrymandering of course for help at the
state level
um they are working on voter suppression
uh closing polling places restricting
early voting hours strategically all of
these different things voter roll purges
on you know the full list and now openly
saying we need our supervisors of
elections in place
in order to make this
more plausible that we would succeed
next time and uh this is part of why
2022 is so important I hope that the
left understands the importance of 2022
midterms
that always you know compared to general
elections midterms have lower turnout
and it's so kind of cliche and
um uh
I don't know what other word to apply to
it to say these are very important
midterms particularly important midterms
and there's always some reason why
someone will say this is the most
important election in a very specific
sense which is when it comes to trying
to steal the elections when they don't
win
2022 could be the Rubicon where once it
is crossed it will be very very
difficult to go back and so we are going
to be getting back into you've got to
vote you've got to vote and I know it
became a broken record leading up to the
2020 election but everyone must vote not
just because if Republicans take control
of the House and Senate it will be a
disaster for the United States not just
because trumpian candidates winning
makes it more likely Trump runs in 2024
and quite frankly I think I think Trump
in 24 beats Joe Biden or Kamala I've
said that before some of you agree some
of you disagree but also because 2022 is
going to be part of the plan for better
positioning themselves to steal future
elections which would be an absolute and
total nightmare uh we're going to take a
break and be back with some very
interesting news headlines uh your
voicemail and so many other things stay
with us we will be right back